this mission is a simple in and out  agent valerian he'll be running solo  only work with my partner hi we're a  team  you're running nearly 20 minutes late  yeah well time flies when you're having  fun  [Music]  welcome to alpha  the city of a thousand planets where for  hundreds of years every species has  shared their knowledge and their  intelligence with each other it's  paradise  [Music]  after centuries of peace and prosperity  an unknown force wants to destroy all we  have created agents valerian and Laura  lein you have less than 10 hours to find  the threat and eliminated  phone universes after us  we need the two of you to be the  guardians of our future  you sure you know you doing  valerian trust me  I'm a good one  [Music]  your destiny is in your hands  I taught him how to do that  you  you